Here's an interesting story that has some
people on the left sort of upset or certainly
at least concerned.
On August 17th, about eight days ago, the
Democratic National Committee removed language
from a draft platform, a draft document calling
for an end to subsidies of fossil fuel companies.
And the Democratic National Committee and
Joe Biden and State Senator Kamala Harris
historically have opposed fossil fuel subsidies.
They've said they would end them.
And it was in a draft document.
And yet eight days ago, the call for the end
to these fossil fuel subsidies was quietly
removed.
Why did it happen?
It's not completely clear.
But there was huge backlash.
A lot of climate activists saw it as a stab
in the back.
Many people alleged that, look, this is Joe
Biden.
He said he was going to do one thing and then
they quietly remove it from the document.
And now all of a sudden, they're no longer
against abolishing fossil fuel subsidies,
which cost somewhere between 20 and 650 billion
dollars each year, depending on what you include
and how you measure it.
And a bunch of people reacted by saying this
exposes the true Biden.
Biden doesn't really want to do the things
he claims he wants to do on climate or on
whatever else.
And it's sort of Biden showing his true colors
now after the backlash.
It's been added back in.
And again, it has been restated that Joe Biden
and Kamala Harris and the DNC support ending
subsidies to fossil fuel companies.
And, of course, the reaction from many was
and it's not a crazy reaction.
Joe Biden doesn't really support it, but he
only got shamed back into it right now.
So you could chalk this up to confusion.
You could chalk it up to a misunderstanding.
You could chalk it up to bad faith.
I have to tell you, it seems unlikely to me
that what happened here is that they really
were trying to just remove this pledge to
end fossil fuel subsidies and they got caught.
And they put it back in.
The way the DNC operates is if they want to
back away from some kind of promise.
They do it and they come up with floury or
non offensive language to defend it.
So I actually think it's more likely that
this was some kind of a confusion or a misunderstanding.
But I think it's instructive in that it sort
of reinforces something I've been talking
about for a while, which is if Joe Biden wins,
we are getting the ball back.
We are not yet putting any points up on the
board to use a sort of football analogy.
And we're going to have to push Joe Biden
if he's president and we're going to have
to push him for the entire time that he is
president.
So I'm not hugely worried about this for two
reasons.
Number one, I actually do think it was probably
some kind of a mistake or misunderstanding
because this is not how the DNC would probably
do this.
Also, more than likely, if they didn't plan
to end fossil fuel subsidies or even try to,
they would just leave it in.
But then just not do it and blame Republicans.
So I just I think that that's probably not
the explanation.
But either way, we are going to have to, as
progressive activists, hold Joe Biden accountable
if we want to get things done and put points
on the board, if he indeed becomes president
of the United States.
So I don't think this was some kind of deliberate
betrayal by Joe Biden.
His campaign seems to have been clear the
whole time.
And by the way, I have to tell you something
else.
On this particular issue of ending fossil
fuel subsidies, it's going to be difficult
to do in four years.
It's going to be difficult to do.
Maybe even in eight years, it should be done.
We should be shifting subsidies away from
fossil fuels and to renewables.
But in practice, it's going to be difficult
to do.
It doesn't mean we shouldn't try.
But part of being able to do it is going to
be getting off of these fuels in the first
place.
And it is kind of a chicken egg scenario as
we continue to be dependent on fossil fuels.
It will be difficult to remove the subsidies
and if we remove the subsidies, it will be
difficult to get off of them because the prices
of fossil fuels will be kept artificially
low by the subsidies themselves.
But it's going to have.
To be a sort of step by step by step.
But the hot takes that are saying this is
proof of Biden this or this is proof of Biden,
that Joe Biden's climate proposal would be
the most progressive of any president.
If Biden wins and either way, we are going
to have to hold him accountable.
And that will be the mission of progressive
media.
I hope that's what I'm anticipating my job
to be for the next four or eight years.
If Joe Biden succeeds at removing Donald Trump
in November.